[موسيقى]
وعلى الجوانكه
قليلا بعد وفاه الملكه اليزابيث حتى
اشتعلت من جديد
على العائله الملكيه من جهه وفي مواجهه
بعض الاعلام البريطاني من جهه اخرى
تحت عنوان خلف الابواب المغلقه ياتي
المسلسل الوثائقي لهاري وماجد ليكشف اكثر
مما كان متوقعا فالمسلسل لا يظهر الخلافات
التي شافت علاقه ماغان بالعائله الملكيه
فقط وانما يبدو فيها هاري غير متردد للكشف
عن تفاصيل قد تؤذي سمعه المؤسسه الملكيه
وكل من هو على علاقه
مؤلمه للاميره ديانا هو الدافع الاساسي
لمهمات هاري الذي يتخوف كما يظهر في
المسلسل من تكريس سيناري والدته التي تظهر
بدورها باكيا خلف كواليس المناسبات
الملكيه
لعنه الزواج من افراد العائله الملكيه
البريطانيه هكذا وصف هاري زواج النساء من
افراد عائلته مصممه على ما يبدو على وضعه
حد لمعاناتهن بدءا من زوجته في ست حلقات
ستروي اللعبه القذره التي تلعبها العائله
الملكيه كما وصفها هاري في تعمير تصعيدي
ان كان توقيت المسلسل صدفه
يبدو ان واقع الخلافات داخل العائله
الملكيه البريطانيه اكثر دراميه من
المسلسل الشهير البترون فما لبثت ان خرجت
العائله الملكيه من حادثه العنصريه التي
طالت عرابه الامير وليم حتى بدات حلقه
جديده من الصراع تمس هذه المره اكثر
الشخصيات اساسيه داخل الهرم الملكي
البريطاني لصباح العربيه من لندن عروب عبد
الحق